La primer pregunta Que me hice
y Que les hago a Uds. es:
¿qué es la pobreza?
Por ahí algunos se imaginan
que la pobreza tiene que ver con esto.
Y la verdad que desde muy chico
creía que la pobreza,
o me hicieron entender que la pobreza
tenía que ver con esto.
Yo soy el quinto de seis hermanos:
Yomi, Mariela, Marcela,
Mauricio, yo y Oscar.
Nacimos en San Juan y nos vinimos
a Buenos Aires a buscar el oro y el moro.
A mi padre le habían prometido
trabajo, casa, auto, éxito.
Esta es la única foto que tengo
de mis padres juntos.
Porque Buenos Aires a mi padre lo mata.
Se termina muriendo
a los pocos años de estar acá.
Y ahí empezó una lucha eterna
por tratar de vivir con dignidad
y por tratar de mejorar la calidad de vida
que nos tocó vivir.
Usurpamos un terreno con mis hermanos.
Éramos pobres,
personas que vivían
en un terreno usurpado.
Que no teníamos a veces
ni siquiera para cenar.
Sin embargo, a pesar de todo esto,
y a pesar de haber vivido
la discriminación
y señalarnos como nos señalaron
durante muchos años a toda mi familia,
a mí había algo que siempre me enamoró
y siempre me gustó.
Yo amo la música, yo soy músico.
Y realmente, descubrí la música a través
de una mujer que cuando la escuchaba
era para mí increíble.
Yo la miraba a ella y era como un ángel.
Yo me sabía todas sus canciones,
todas sus letras, todas sus coreografías.
Me aprendí todas las melodías,
tenía todos sus casetes.
En esa época había casetes.
Y realmente para mí
era una estrella, era un ángel.
Esta mujer era Gladys, la bomba tucumana.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Yo soñaba con Gladys.
Una vez le dije a mi mamá:
"Mamá, quiero ser Gladys".
(Risas)
Y me dijo: "Ay hijo, ¿no te gusta
Antonio Ríos o Alcides?".
No, yo quería ser Gladys.
Y mi mamá me decía:
"Bueno, pero La Nueva Luna".
No, yo soñaba con alguna vez
ser una artista como ella.
Siempre soñé con aprender
a tocar sus temas.
Un gran amigo mío de la infancia, Edgardo,
su mamá, Olga, trabajaba en el barrio
desarrollando proyectos
para que personas como yo,
que vivíamos en estos barrios,
pudiéramos estudiar.
Hacían un proyecto en
la Fundación Crear vale la pena
que trabajaba con el arte
en contexto de pobreza.
Mi amigo me dijo un día:
"Daniel, ¿por qué no te dejás de
romper las bolas con la música
y te anotás en el centro
cultural comunitario?",
donde daban talleres gratuitos
de teclado y piano.
Yo le dije: "No, ¿yo voy
a tomar clases de piano?
Ridículo. Yo tengo que salir a hacer
que nuestra vida tenga sentido.
Y él me decía: "Pero andá, anotate
a la clase de piano".
Y me anoté en la clase de piano.
Los sábados a las 9 de la mañana.
Decías "Ah, ¡qué lindo!".
En esta Fundación había
una profesora, concertista de piano,
Liliana Alpern, que daba
una vez por semana
un par de horas de clases gratis
a las personas no podíamos pagar la clase.
Fui a la clase de piano
cuando tenía nueve años.
Y la vi a Lili, mi profesora de piano,
con tacos, un chal de seda,
anteojos, ojos verdes, rubia.
Y yo la miré y ella me miró
y me dijo: "¿Cómo te llamás?".
"Daniel". "¿Y qué hacés acá?"
Había un piano vertical al lado de ella.
Le dije: "Yo quiero tocar eso".
Y me dice: "¿Ah sí? ¿Y qué querés tocar?".
(Risas)
Y yo le dije: "Gladys, la bomba tucumana".
Y ella me dijo: "¿Y quién es esa mujer?".
(Risas)
"¿Cómo? ¿Usted no es profesora de música?"
"Sí, la verdad es que sí,
pero no conozco a todos los músicos.
Pero si vos traes un casete de ella,
yo lo escucho y te enseño".
"¿En serio?", le dije yo. "Sí".
Voy a mi casa, agarro el casete
lo traigo y Lili empezó:
"Si si si si si, do re, do re mi,
mi fa sol, si do".
(Risas)
Y yo dije: ¡guau!
Me empezó a enseñar y yo me sentía
que era John Lennon tocando Imagine.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
O sea, impresionante.
(Fin de aplausos)
Lili me dijo: "Mirá Daniel, vos podés
aprender esto y mucho más,
si vos querés".
"¿En serio, profe?".
"Sí. Vos podes aprender
todo lo que quieras aprender".
Y al otro sábado le llevé La Nueva Luna,
Los Charros, Gilda.
Aprendía a tocar una banda que se llamaba
Los Palmeras, yo soñaba con Los Palmeras.
Y me enseñó toda la música
que yo quería aprender.
Al poco tiempo, yo ya había aprendido
todo lo que quería.
Y Lili me dijo: "Y ahora,
¿qué querés aprender?".
Y yo dije: "Ya está, yo ya aprendí
a tocar lo que quería aprender".
Y me dice: "Mirá Daniel,
con estos mismos acordes
existe un tipo que se llama Beethoven.
¿Sabés quién es Beethoven?".
Le dije yo: "Sí, un perro
en una película".
(Risas)
"No, querido, Beethoven no es un perro.
Beethoven es un músico
que toca 'Para Elisa'".
Y me mostró "Para Elisa".
Cuando escuché "Para Elisa", me enamoré.
Y dije: "Lili, ¿yo puedo tocar eso?".
Y Lili me dijo: "Vos podés tocar eso
y mucho más, Daniel.
Todo lo que vos querás tocar".
Y ahí aprendí a los nueve años
a romper con la primera pobreza.
Que es la pobreza de lo cultural.
Yo solamente pensé que la música era --
(Aplausos)
Yo pensé que la música era
lo que escuchaba en mi barrio,
pero no sabía que existía
otro tipo de música.
Y así aprendí a ser, no solamente músico,
sino a los 14 años, Lili,
me vuelve a poner un desafío
con una compañera que tocábamos
los dos piano juntos, Marcela Tula,
que los dos íbamos a clase.
"Ahora Uds., después de 5 años de tomar
clases gratis en el centro cultural
tienen que empezar a dar clase a otros".
Y yo dije: "No, ¿yo, Lili?
Yo no puedo dar clases a otros".
"Sí, Uds. pueden dar clase a otros".
"Pero, Lili, yo no tengo nada para dar".
Y me dice: "Para dar, no hace falta
que tengas algo en el bolsillo.
Lo único que tenés que hacer
es querer ayudar a otros".
Entonces empecé a dar clases en mi barrio.
Con Marcela, aprendimos
los dos a dar clases.
En el barrio dábamos clases a jóvenes,
los más principiantes del barrio.
Pasé a ser del pibe que se juntaba
en la esquina a mandarse cagadas
a "el profesor del barrio".
Yo pasaba por la vereda
y me decían: "Profe, profe".
Pasaba como cuatro veces por la vereda.
Iba al almacén y me decían:
"¿Cómo le va profesor? Tome un caramelo".
Y yo agarraba como cinco.
La hija del almacenero era mi alumna.
Y ahí aprendí a derribar otra pobreza,
que es la pobreza de la dignidad.
Que es la pobreza que se pierde porque
uno por vivir en los contextos que vivimos
piensa que la pobreza solamente
tiene que ver con el hambre
y el frío que uno siente
a la noche, pero no.
La pobreza poco tiene que ver
con lo económico.
Sino tiene que ver en qué haces vos
para proyectar tu proyecto de vida.
Qué hacés vos para poder decir
quién sos, sin importar el título,
ni el cargo que tengas en una empresa.
Sino quién sos como persona.
Y eso yo aprendí a los 14 años para
empezar a dar clases a otros en mi barrio.
A los 17 años...
(Aplausos)
A los 17 años empecé a coordinar
el centro cultural comunitario
con actividades con jóvenes de los barrios
donde ya no me importaba
solamente aprender yo y enseñar yo.
Sino lo que hacíamos este grupo de jóvenes
era formarnos y empezar a pensar
sobre cómo nuestra comunidad,
cómo nuestro barrio
podía hacer actividades
para mejorar la calidad de vida
ya no solamente de los que estudiábamos,
sino de nuestra comunidad.
Hacíamos eventos en los barrios,
festejábamos el Día del niño,
buscábamos las necesidades
de nuestros barrios
y empezábamos a mejorar,
no solo nuestra vida,
sino la vida de nuestros vecinos.
A los 25 años me voy de esta fundación
porque sentí que en Crear vale la pena
yo ya había pasado desde alumno,
docente, coordinador, director ejecutivo,
inclusive, hasta formaba jóvenes
en temas políticos.
Y empecé a entender que tenía
que poder derribar otra de las pobrezas.
Entonces empecé a trabajar
con una organización civil
que se llama Inicia.
Y lo que hicimos en Inicia fue
trabajar en el penal.
Porque un joven del penal,
el hijo de una amiga mía,
lo vamos a ver porque estaba ahí preso.
Cuando fui al penal lo primero que vi
fueron esos dibujos que Uds.
ven atrás de los jóvenes,
era como una galería de arte,
eran todos dibujos donde ellos habían
dibujado todo lo que ellos querían.
Lo miré a Cristian junto con Olga
y le dijimos: "Che, Cristian,
¿qué hacen acá en el penal?".
"Nada".
"¿Cómo Cristián?"
"Nada. El lunes nada,
el martes nada, el jueves nada..."
"¿Y si yo te propongo un taller donde Uds.
puedan pensar en el error que cometieron
por el cual están acá adentro
y puedan pensar un proyecto para
una vez que salgan del penal?".
Y Cristian me contestó:
"¿Vos harías eso por mí?".
"Claro que sí".
Entonces empezamos un taller
donde hablábamos de liderazgo,
de que ellos puedan liderar
su proyecto de vida.
Teníamos un libro que se llama
"Los nuevos líderes",
que era de esta asociación civil.
Y tenía capítulos como:
"La transformación personal",
"El bien común", "La ética"
o "Los valores".
Cada capítulo lo leíamos con los presos
con los 48 presos que fueron al taller.
Y no solamente eso,
sino que armábamos un cómic
y cada uno podía poner en el cómic
lo que se quedaba de ese capítulo.
Y ahí rompí otra pobreza,
que es la pobreza del prejuicio.
Uno piensa que las personas
que están privadas de su libertad
no solo se merecen estar ahí,
sino que tampoco tienen
ni la capacidad ni la dignidad
de poder cambiar su futuro.
Sí, pueden cambiar su futuro.
Lo único que necesitan son oportunidades.
Y yo, ahí lo que estaba brindando
era una oportunidad.
Pero no solamente con esta pobreza
derribé la pobreza del prejuicio.
Después me tocó trabajar en otro proyecto
donde un compañero, un conocido,
un gastronómico que tenía
en el bajo de San Isidro
una cadena de restaurantes,
me dijo: "Che, Dani,
enfrente de mis restaurantes
está la villa Martín y Omar
y la verdad, no sé qué hacer,
porque cada vez que paso por ahí me dicen:
'Eh, bigote, ¿tené laburo pa mí?'
Y yo no sé qué hacer".
Entonces hicimos un programa
que se llama Cocina para Integrar
¿Qué es lo que hacíamos?
Este gastronómico les enseñaba
a las mujeres de la villa Martín
y Omar a que sean chefs,
que puedan formarse ya no solo como
personas que se dedican a las changas,
sino también en un oficio
como el gastronómico.
Y ahí rompí otro prejuicio,
y ahí rompí otra pobreza,
que era la pobreza de pensar
que personas que viven
en contexto de vulnerabilidad
solamente pueden trabajar de changarines.
No, son profesionales que también
se pueden formar en oficios,
como el oficio de ser chef.
En el camino me encontré
con otra persona que también me ayudó
a romper otra de mis pobrezas.
Nos conocimos en una charla juntos
y él tenía una empresa donde desarrollaba
productos con diseño,
un calzado con diseño distinto.
Él da su charla, una empresa joven
que exportaba a países de todo el mundo.
Yo doy mi charla y me dice:
"Dani, tenés que trabajar conmigo".
Y yo le dije: "Tomás, ¿en qué querés
que labure con vos en la empresa?".
"Vos tenés que hacer en mi empresa
lo que hacés en los barrios.
Tenés que trabajar en mi barrio
que es mi empresa, con mi comunidad,
con mis empleados".
"¿Y qué querés que haga?".
"Quiero que seas el gerente
de Recursos Humanos".
Y yo le dije: "Pero, Tomás,
yo no sé ni liquidar sueldos".
Me dice: "No me importa,
eso lo vas a aprender,
lo que vos sabés es escuchar
y estar con la gente".
Después de trabajar tres años con él
me propone ser además más que eso.
Y soy hoy el gerente
de Cultura y Felicidad.
En el sector privado me dedico --
(Aplausos)
Ya no solamente me dedico hoy
a trabajar en los barrios,
a mejorar la calidad de vida
de las personas,
sino también las empresas empiezan
a pensar que todas las personas
que trabajan en una empresa pueden
mejorar su calidad de vida
y tienen que trabajar siendo felices
y trabajar la cultura de esa empresa.
(Aplausos)
Uds. me preguntarán hoy,
¿y cuál es tu riqueza?
Mi riqueza tiene que ver con esto,
con haber formado una familia,
con mi mujer, con mis hermanos,
con mis amigos.
Ser padre de Lautaro y Catalina,
que tiene dos meses de vida.
Y yo les quiero decir algo:
cualquiera de los que está acá
cualquiera puede ser una Liliana Alpern.
Cualquiera de Uds. le puede dedicar
una vez por semana a alguien
para que transforme su vida.
(Aplausos)
A pesar de su pobreza económica
o de su riqueza económica,
no hagan de su vida una vida pobre.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)